uh in a previous set of lessons we
talked about how you can take a plane or
a footage file and turn it on it's like
90 degrees on its side and then use a
camera and create a more interesting
look to that graphic or footage or
photography
we did it with a grid so i want to show
you
um something even more advanced now to
take it even a step further um this is a
technique that i picked up from andrew
kramer we all know who andrew kramer is
years ago he created this uh
very simple technique to create a
a grid like a
kind of like a sci-fi
oh it's not like a perfect grid it's
just something it's very uh organic it's
pretty cool so we're to call this uh
advanced grid it's a technique i picked
up from him and i'm just doing my own
spin on it
so this first part will be
based on what i learned from him which
is we're just going to call this
grid
and what he taught was that you take
um
under generate advanced lightning that's
what it was um and you turn advanced
lightning into a grid so
you're gonna turn the opacity so there's
no glow so we're down to zero we're
gonna change the type lightning type to
bouncy
so there we go and we're gonna go into
core settings are fine we're gonna crank
the turbulence all the way up to 10
and then we're gonna go into expert
settings and we're gonna take the
complexity
down to two
and we're gonna bring it down here we're
going to just it takes some um
some trial and error to get it to work
right
but that's essentially it right there
you're gonna also play around with the
decay a little bit um and it just
depends what you wanna do for decay
um
you know how much you wanna see of it um
after that that's what i learned from
him so what i'm doing next now is i'm
going to duplicate the advanced
lightning i'm going to say composite on
original
so that we can put another set of this
on top and then i just play around with
the origin
so i'm going to try and just kind of you
know fill up this
solid
with these with this effect so i
duplicate it again and again i'm just
playing around the origin here
um
i want something up in here
so maybe
but here's so funny how it reacts
and maybe we'll do it one more time
and
there we go now let's take it over here
maybe something like that
it might not be enough but we'll we'll
see
so now we've got our our basic grid set
up
i'm going to make this layer 3d i'm
going to rotate it
negative 90
on its x-axis so now we can't see it
it is there there it is i'm going to add
a camera
layer new camera
with 35 millimeter
depth of field sure and we're going to
hit r for rotation and we're just going
to rotate it
on
the
x-axis
and hit
c
for my camera rotate tool and just
something like this
something like that
now i want this grid to extend all the
way back here i could
duplicate this layer and drag it back
on the y-axis and just keep going back
back back in space
but a cheat a easy way to get around
this is to use the reptile which i had
pulled up there it's under stylize
so if we go over here to effect
make sure layers
selected effect stylize
repetile and now i can't find it
where are you at
repertile cc reptile there we go
so we're going to expand up
and we're going to crank this way up
to keep going maybe somewhere way up in
here or something like that
we're also going to
change this from repeat to unfold
yeah looks pretty cool
um
so we'll start there
okay
and let's move in a little bit closer
here
on our grid so i want to create a loop
so to do that i need to make sure i
don't see
up in here
so maybe what we'll do is just go a
little bit higher
now
that's too much i don't want to go too
high up in there
but maybe something like that
and then
we're going to hit a a make sure if the
field is on it is on and we're going to
crank up that aperture again
and i want to bring this focus distance
up in here
so we'll just
click and drag and just bring that focus
distance forward i'm just watching what
it does
visually
you know that's pretty cool right there
that's that's nice i like that
maybe i don't i think the aperture is
pretty good right there
sometimes i'll play around with the
amount of blur
and crank it up but typically
100 which is where it's at right there
is just great
next i'm going to do is instead of
animating the camera i'm actually going
to animate
well actually we are going to animate
the camera let's do that let's do that
so let's just do a simple
how about a simple z rotation
and we'll just kind of sway back and
forth so we'll do a negative 15
and we'll set this to an easy ease
and we'll go halfway
here which is three seconds and we'll do
positive 15
and at the very end we'll go back
to negative 15.
and maybe i'll just drag that right
there
so it's just a simple swaying
motion that we can just
loop and it'll just you know go back and
forth so the next thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna animate the grid and like
i said i could animate the camera moving
over this but instead let's just do it
something different this time let's just
animate the grid coming towards us so
i'll hit p for position
and i found
that the values of about 180
set a keyframe here and i'll go to my
end of my timeline
to a negative
1960
creates a fairly decent loop at least on
the tests it did
you never know when i rebuild these
things
if it's going to look the same
looks pretty close
so let's go ahead and just do a preview
of this
okay so there's playing back
and it's looking pretty good
i like what i see here um i do see a
little bit of a pop back here for the
loop and that's because we go back to
the beginning and there's a little bit
more
uh repetile going on here that of course
is gone at the end because we're moving
it's moving past us
so that's okay i'm also using a kind of
a crappy
irish shape so if we were to change this
to something like hexagon again it's
going to look a little bit nicer there
it's going to take longer to render
um
but let's see if i can just get rid of
this background here maybe negative
18.
and then push in just a hair more
oh maybe make it negative
19.
that might do it it might be too much
yeah i can still see that background
kind of pop off a little bit there
uh but this will do it for now the last
thing i want to show you now is because
um you know working in in 2.5 d
doing simple things like repeating and
changing the position just slightly
makes a huge difference so let's just do
that let's just duplicate this layer
let's bring it to the bottom
let's turn off our position
and
let's just change it i deleted the
keyframes there let's just change it to
i don't know 340.
that takes it above so we'll go
let's just go
600 so we added 60 to this we dropped it
below
we're going to
duplicate it again and we're going to
drop this one
to 660 because i'm ocd i like to have
things even
and
that looks pretty good
now i'm just going to
parent both of these layers to my layer
that has the position keyframes which
you can see here
because remember we deleted the position
keyframes here it's just
less keyframes to deal with if i want to
move things around which i do
because i'm going to move them around
just slightly on the y axis and just to
give it a little bit of variance
so it's not the same shape repeating
down down down which you could do that
and it would probably look really nice
and then this one i'm just going to
maybe
drag forward
just a hair
something like that
or maybe i'll just maybe i'll do the
opposite maybe i'll go backwards again i
like to
talk did that look
something like that and let's just take
a preview of this
so
looking at this preview it's it's pretty
close it's still a little bit too
repetitive for me
[Music]
so i just want to offset it just a hair
more
yeah that works for that one
um i think that's all i need to do
maybe turn down that depth of field just
a touch
and play that back
and there we go so there's just a little
bit of a hiccup there at the end
you could probably add like a um
like a solid
type of mat over that feathered and it
would hide that but i really like
this kind of you know it's a futuristic
grid it's very organic but it's just
this simple movement of adding a camera
with some shallow depth of field and
some simple movements what is what
really makes it shine
and
you know me i can't ever
let this stuff
die so i have to fix that end so um
call this cover up
and
let's do a simple
like feather on this
and something like
a pretty high feather
um i should say if you want to stick
around
you'll see me
try and fix this if not i get it
i'm gonna do is try and cover this up
i need to reduce the feather so i want
it to be completely dark up in here
and then home brings me to beginning my
timeline
end is the end there we go
perfect
and there we go perfect loop i'm happy
with that
thanks for watching
[Music]
you